Se ruoti una palla attorno a un asse e poi attorno a un altro, non è la stessa cosa che fare le due rotazioni nell'ordine inverso.
Oggi in Qiskit in the classroom vedremo cosa c'entra questa palla con i computer quantistici e uno dei principi più famosi
della meccanica quantistica: il principio di
indeterminazione. Benvenuto a Qiskit in the classroom, una serie di video in cui approfondiamo un concetto fondamentale che potresti
incontrare in un corso legato al Quantum Computing. Ogni video è accompagnato da un modulo interattivo collegato nella
descrizione qui sotto, quindi assicurati di controllarlo. Oggi parliamo del principio di indeterminazione di Heisenberg. Se
ne hai già sentito parlare, potresti aver sentito anche la vecchia barzelletta su Heisenberg: un giorno viene fermato mentre guidava e il poliziotto gli chiede: sai
a che velocità andavi? Heisenberg risponde: no, ma so esattamente dove sono. Questo è in un certo senso
il principio di indeterminazione di Heisenberg in sintesi: non puoi conoscere simultaneamente la posizione e il momento di una particella
con perfetta precisione. Si scrive spesso così: Delta x per Delta p è maggiore
o uguale a h/ 2, dove Delta X e Delta P sono le
incertezze nella posizione e nel momento, e H è una piccola costante fondamentale della meccanica quantistica.
Heisenberg formulò questa disuguaglianza nel 1927 mentre immaginava come misurare la posizione di un elettrone. Se
rimbalzavi un fotone su di esso per vedere dov'è, quel fotone inevitabilmente avrebbe urtato l'elettrone e perturbato il suo
momento. Questo non è solo un'affermazione sul fatto che le misurazioni disturbano un sistema: ci dice che ci sono limiti fondamentali
a quanto possiamo imparare sulla natura. Questo è un esempio di un principio più ampio chiamato complementarità, che
afferma che certi aspetti della natura sono incompatibili tra loro e non possono essere osservati
simultaneamente. Ad esempio, gli oggetti quantistici a volte si comportano come particelle e a volte come onde,
ma non puoi osservare entrambi i comportamenti simultaneamente. La relazione posizione-momento di Heisenberg copriva solo una delle
molte coppie di caratteristiche complementari. Questa incertezza intrinseca ha a che fare con come vediamo le proprietà come
posizione e momento nella meccanica quantistica. Invece di pensare a X e P come variabili o proprietà intrinseche
che ogni particella possiede, nella meccanica quantistica posizione e momento sono operatori. Non sono proprietà di un
sistema ma cose che puoi fare a un sistema. Imparare la posizione di una particella ora richiede di eseguire un'
operazione su quel sistema e fare una misurazione. Questa operazione potrebbe influenzare il risultato di altre operazioni successive.
Come analogia, pensa a un pezzo di legno secco. Ha molte proprietà come la sua
posizione, dimensione, forma. Ha anche la proprietà di essere combustibile e di galleggiare nell'acqua. Se questo legno fosse un
oggetto quantistico, queste non sarebbero proprietà che potresti semplicemente conoscere a priori. Invece diciamo che sono
osservabili: cose che puoi imparare sul sistema se esegui qualche operazione su di esso. Quindi dovresti applicare gli operatori di
combustibilità o galleggiabilità, il che richiederebbe di provare effettivamente a bruciare il legno o di metterlo in
acqua per vedere se galleggia. Ora il risultato di ognuno di questi operatori dipende dall'ordine in cui li applichi. Se
prima testi la combustibilità, il legno brucerà in cenere e non potrai verificare se galleggia. Ma se testi
prima la galleggiabilità, sarà troppo bagnato per bruciare. Diciamo che la combustibilità e
la galleggiabilità non commutano: l'ordine delle operazioni è importante. Questo porta a un limite fondamentale
su quanto bene queste due osservabili possono essere conosciute del pezzo di legno, poiché non possiamo dire con certezza se è
combustibile o galleggiante senza conoscere il contesto di quella misurazione. Certo, con un vero pezzo di legno
potresti tagliarlo a metà e testare entrambe quelle proprietà simultaneamente, ma non puoi fare nulla di simile con una particella quantistica. Questa
analogia con il legno è solo questo: un'analogia. L'incertezza è una cosa uniquamente quantistica. X e P non commutano anch'essi,
e questa proprietà di non-commutatività è ciò che porta al principio di indeterminazione di Heisenberg. In generale, qualsiasi due operatori
che non commutano avranno il loro principio di indeterminazione. La forma generale del principio di indeterminazione può essere
scritta così: Delta a per Delta
B è maggiore o uguale a
1/2 volte a e b, dove
questa parentesi è chiamata il
commutatore, e ciò è uguale alla differenza tra applicare prima a e poi
B, e applicare prima B e poi a. Queste parentesi angolari
segnalano che stai prendendo quello che si chiama il valore di aspettazione di ciò che c'è dentro. In pratica, se facessi la stessa
misurazione molte volte, il valore di aspettazione è il valore medio di tutte quelle misurazioni. Oggi
testeremo e verificheremo effettivamente questo principio di indeterminazione su un computer quantistico IBM. Osserveremo tre diverse
osservabili di un qubit, mostreremo che i loro operatori non commutano e infine potremo dimostrare che il
principio di indeterminazione vale per queste osservabili del qubit. Prima, una breve parentesi su un modo utile per visualizzare lo stato quantistico
di un qubit. Può essere rappresentato da un vettore che punta in qualche punto su una sfera chiamata sfera di Bloch. L'ho trattata
in un video precedente, collegato nella descrizione, ma ti darò anche un rapido riepilogo qui. Ecco la
sfera di Bloch. Ogni vettore è parametrizzato da due angoli Theta e F.
Lo stato zero è al polo nord e lo stato uno è al polo sud. Una sovrapposizione uguale di 0 e uno è
da qualche parte lungo l'equatore, dove f è uguale alla fase relativa tra le due parti della
sovrapposizione. Quindi questo stato qui sarebbe uguale
a 1 / radice di 2 per 0 + e alla i per 1, dove i è quella
fase. Quando misuriamo un'osservabile del qubit, il risultato è sempre una di due opzioni corrispondenti ai due
possibili stati del qubit. Per l'esperimento che stiamo per fare, osserveremo tre osservabili e
i loro operatori corrispondenti X, Y e Z. Quando misuri una qualsiasi di queste osservabili, ottieni più uno o
meno uno, con una probabilità per ciascuno che dipende dall'angolo tra il vettore del qubit sulla sfera di Bloch e
l'asse di misurazione. Come ci si aspetterebbe, Z misura lungo l'asse Z, X lungo X
e Y lungo Y. Ricorda che stiamo parlando di osservabili perché con un sistema quantistico
non possiamo più semplicemente sapere cose sul sistema senza misurarle.
E ogni osservabile ha un'operazione corrispondente, perché le misurazioni richiedono operazioni. Potrebbe non essere ovvio, ma
si scopre che le operazioni, chiamate operatori, corrispondenti a ognuna di queste osservabili x, y e z sono
rotazioni di Pi attorno ai rispettivi assi. Quindi X è una rotazione attorno a X, Y
attorno a Y e Z attorno a Z. Quindi per vedere se questi operatori commutano o no, possiamo verificare se le rotazioni
su una sfera commutano. Se lo fanno, il principio di indeterminazione non si applicherà e potremmo conoscere X, Y e Z di un qubit
con perfetta precisione. Se non commutano, potremo trovare una nuova relazione di indeterminazione per il qubit. Guarda
il punto su questa palla mentre ruoto prima attorno a X e poi attorno a Y: finisce
qui. Ora proviamo nell'ordine inverso: ruoto prima attorno a Y e
poi attorno a X. Finisce lì. Quindi non commutano assolutamente. Questo significa
che non possiamo conoscere simultaneamente i valori esatti di X, Y e Z di un qubit. Avremo una
relazione di indeterminazione. Sorvoliamo i dettagli qui, ma otteniamo tre diverse relazioni di
indeterminazione. Quindi abbiamo Delta x per Delta Y
è maggiore o uguale a Z; Delta Y per Delta Z è maggiore o uguale
a X; e Delta Z per Delta X è maggiore o uguale
a Y. Quindi il prodotto di due qualsiasi di queste incertezze è sempre maggiore o uguale
al valore di aspettazione della terza osservabile. Usiamo Qiskit per vedere cosa
succede quando proviamo a misurare sia Z che X dello stato zero. Misurare Z è facile: è la cosiddetta base standard
del computer quantistico. Le misurazioni sono sempre lungo Z per impostazione predefinita. Ma per misurare X dobbiamo eseguire qualcosa chiamato
cambio di base: in pratica ruotare la sfera di Bloch in modo che X punti ora verso l'alto dove puntava Z. Per farlo
usiamo un gate Hadamard. Quindi il circuit quantistico completo avrà questo aspetto: misuriamo in Z, applichiamo il Hadamard
e poi misuriamo in X. Se usiamo la primitiva di Qiskit sampler per eseguire questo esperimento molte volte, otteniamo
un istogramma dei risultati delle misurazioni che appare così per la misurazione Z
e così per la misurazione in X. Come puoi vedere, abbiamo misurato il
qubit nello stato zero lungo Z con quasi il 100% di certezza, ma
lungo X non sapevamo praticamente nulla dello stato del qubit: è stato misurato come zero o uno con uguale
probabilità, il che significa che la nostra incertezza in X era grande quanto può essere. Questo ci dà
una piccola idea di questo scambio di incertezze, ma possiamo fare un po' meglio sul nostro computer quantistico. Possiamo usare una
primitiva di Qiskit chiamata estimator per trovare i valori di aspettazione delle nostre osservabili X, Y e Z e l'
incertezza in ciascuna. Proviamolo per lo stato che punta nella direzione più X sulla sfera di Bloch. Useremo estimator
per calcolare le incertezze in x e z per questo stato e il valore di aspettazione di
Y. Con questo stato otteniamo questo risultato da Qiskit. Quando prendiamo il prodotto delle due
incertezze in X e Y, vediamo che, come previsto, è maggiore del valore assoluto
del valore di aspettazione di Y. Ma questo era solo per un particolare stato. Vogliamo assicurarci che questa disuguaglianza
valga per tutti gli stati del qubit. Quindi usiamo di nuovo estimator, ma questa volta gli chiederemo di scansionare i valori di un
parametro e di trovare i valori di aspettazione per ogni singolo valore del parametro che gli diamo. Qui il parametro che vogliamo
scansionare è l'angolo Theta sulla sfera di Bloch, in modo da verificare la disuguaglianza per tutti gli stati del qubit che si trovano su
questo arco che interseca il piano XZ. Quando lo facciamo, otteniamo un grafico in funzione dell'angolo Theta. La curva rossa
è il prodotto delle due incertezze e la curva arancione è il valore di aspettazione di Y. Come previsto,
il prodotto delle incertezze in x e z è molto più alto del valore di aspettazione di Y, ma non era
troppo difficile soddisfare la disuguaglianza perché il valore di aspettazione di Y era così basso: era zero per tutti gli stati su
questo arco. Facciamo una scansione simile attraverso i valori di Theta, ma invece di scansionare nel piano XZ, impostiamo phi uguale a pi/
4. Quindi osserviamo gli stati del qubit che si trovano su un arco diverso sulla sfera. Qui vediamo che la disuguaglianza viene
testata un po' di più, poiché la curva arancione e la curva rossa sono più vicine, ma la rossa è sempre sopra l'arancione
e il principio di indeterminazione vale ancora. Non abbiamo ancora verificato tutti gli stati, ma speriamo che tu stia iniziando a capire
l'idea: c'è un'inconoscibilità fondamentale riguardo a qualsiasi due aspetti complementari di un sistema quantistico,
incluso questo qubit che abbiamo usato. Il principio di indeterminazione ci costringe a confrontarci con il fatto che non importa
quanto ci proviamo, non importa quanto siano intelligenti le nostre misurazioni, non sapremo mai tutto con perfetta precisione.
Non c'è modo di aggirarlo, davvero. Se non mi credi, o anche se mi credi, ti sfido: vai a controllare il modulo
collegato nella descrizione e prova a battere il principio di indeterminazione. Grazie per aver guardato e ci vediamo la prossima volta.